bonjour à tous je m'appelle Samia je
suis comorienne je réside actuellement
en France et je suis une endogueur quand
j'ai su que je devais raconter mon
parcours durant cette conférence
tedxmooni je me suis remémoré plein de
souvenirs en lien avec la raison de ma
présence parmi vous ce jour je me suis
je suis remontée jusqu'à ma tendre
enfance et à l'époque j'essayais de
comprendre mon corps qui semblait déjà
me dire que quelque chose n'allait pas
bien il y a quelques temps une personne
de mon entourage m'a demandé pourquoi tu
dis que tu es une endogueur et c'est
quoi ton super pouvoir je suis resté
abasourdi quelques instants et
j'entendais encore cette personne qui me
répétait c'est quoi ton super pouvoir ça
n'a endogueur je me suis rendu compte
qu'elle ne savait pas ce que c'était une
endrogueur et que dans sa tête elle
pensait que ce mot en deux girl
désignait une femme qui a une casquette
d'entrepreneur ou chef de projet ou qui
est patronne d'une société comme s'il
s'agissait d'un slogan de girl boss
alors que pas du tout le monde en doc
Girl est nos contractions de
endométriose et girl fille en anglais
tout simplement qui désigne donc une
femme ou une fille atteindre
d'endométriose c'est une maladie
gynécologique qui touche une femme sur
dix dans le monde principalement en âge
de procréer il peut se manifester dès le
début des premières règles tout comme
elle peut se déclencher plus tard
jusqu'à la ménopause les symptômes les
plus répandus de cette maladie
endométriose sont très variées il y a
les règles abondantes et douloureuses
qui sont invalidantes et qu'on
appréhende tous les mois qui nous
empêchent de mener normalement notre
quotidien qui nous font vomir parfois et
perdre conscience même ce sont des
douleurs menstruelles qui ne passent pas
avec des antalgiques classiques et des
douleurs qu'on ne cesse de signaler
comme pas normal qu'ils nous empêchent
de sortir ou de travailler tout
simplement d'autres symptômes de
l'endométriose sont les douleurs pendant
les rapports intimes des douleurs
pelviennes aussi très fréquentes ou
encore des troubles urinaires par
exemple quand on a envie de faire pipi
et que ça ne sort pas ou quand ça sort
avec difficulté
ça peut être un des symptômes de
l'endométriose et parfois les deux
situations aussi sont possibles soit
pendant l'envie ou après avoir pu enfin
faire pipi il y a aussi des troubles
digestifs qui peuvent être liés à une
diarrhée ou à une constipation chronique
des douleurs lombaires et plein d'autres
symptômes qui varient d'une femme à une
autre ou d'une endométriose à une autre
car il y en a plusieurs d'endométriose
pendant distingue vraiment de nombreuses
et comme on aime le préciser il n'y a
vraiment pas une seule mais plusieurs
types d'endométriose c'est une maladie
dont on ne guérit pas à ce jour qui
reste très complexe à vivre et à
comprendre et surtout difficile à
diagnostiquer et en parlant de
diagnostic et constitue encore un
parcours de combattants pour certaines
femmes et jeunes filles la durée est
vraiment vraiment très longue il peut
s'écouler jusqu'à 10 ans en moyenne
avant qu'un diagnostic ne soit posé ce
qui a été mon cas j'ai été diagnostiquée
de l'endométriose en 2019 après 17 ans
d'errance médicale une dizaine d'années
à souffrir chaque mois sans savoir
pourquoi je souffrais autant technique
pourquoi on me disait que c'était normal
c'est de l'or pendant les règles et rien
jusqu'à présent malheureusement ne me
soulage un tout petit peu il faut savoir
que j'ai eu mes premiers règles à l'âge
de 10 ans et dès le début j'ai eu de
fortes douleurs qui s'accentuent encore
aujourd'hui certains de ces douleurs
liées à l'endométriose en surgit avant
les premiers saignements de règles
j'avais 27 ans quand j'ai pu mettre un
mot sur ces douleurs chroniques et je
n'étais pas encore au bout de mes
surprises on m'a immédiatement dit qu'il
fallait que je sois opéré car la maladie
avait déjà beaucoup pris d'avance sur
mon organisme et la chirurgie est l'une
des solutions qui permettent à une
personne souffrant d'endométriose
d'aller mieux elle consiste
essentiellement à limiter la progression
de la maladie et à proposer un
traitement qui pourra être efficace par
la suite aujourd'hui j'ai 30 ans et
j'insiste sur le temps car nous sommes
nombreuses à souffrir de cette maladie
dans le silence et pendant des années et
même si on en guérit pas encore une
bonne fois pour toute sachez qu'elle se
soigne l'endométriose et ses soins
peuvent être efficaces que si le
diagnostic n'est pas c'est trop tard
d'où la nécessité de ne jamais douter de
ses douleurs et de persévérer pour
trouver des réponses à cette souffrance
quotidienne dans mon cas le diagnostic
tardif a indiqué un stade 3 sur 4 ce qui
est déjà quand même un assez avancé même
si je tiens à préciser que l'on parle
d'au moins en moins de stade de
l'endogueur car il y a des femmes avec
un stade avancé d'endométriose qui ont
des douleurs moins pénibles comme il y
en a d'autres qui ont un stade plus
avancé et qui ressentent de plus fortes
douleurs hépice versa plusieurs femmes
dans leur dialogue plusieurs femmes
déclarent être soulagés quand elles
apprennent que leur quotidien menstruel
n'était pas le fruit de leur imagination
car beaucoup de personnes banalisent les
douleurs liées aux règles et pensent que
les filles et les femmes qui s'en
plaignent et ne font qu'exagérer pour ma
part je n'ai pas ressenti de soulagement
et c'est peut-être un peu triste mais
c'est la vérité peu importe qui me
croyait ou pas je savais que ce que je
ressentais était bien réel et ce que je
ressens aujourd'hui il est encore plus
il faut savoir que
ne se limite pas qu'à la période des
règles les douleurs liées à cette
maladie peuvent aussi être présentes
dans d'autres régions du corps et se
manifestent donc différemment il y a des
endogueurs comme moi qui ont des
douleurs neuropathiques lombaires ou
encore vésicales tous les jours le type
d'endométriose que j'ai perturbe
fortement mon corps dans ton regard car
elle menace aussi ma fertilité qui est
l'une des causes chez la femme et même
c'est parti de la minorité touchée par
ce trouble je garde beaucoup d'espoir et
je me soigne surtout car il ne faut pas
oublier qu'il y a quand même 65% de
femmes en de Girls qui arrivent à
concevoir et qui sont très fertiles et
ça c'est magnifique moi qui ai toujours
été une personne très active dans ma vie
autant scolaire que professionnelle et
social je peux vous dire que aujourd'hui
cette maladie a des conséquences énormes
sur mon quotidien et l'évoque chez moi
une grosse fatigue chronique souvent due
aux nombreux traitements médicamenteux
du quotidien et les gens ne comprennent
pas forcément à quel point cela peut
être pesant comme routine l'endométriose
sus beaucoup d'incompréhension autour de
moi car j'ai un suivi médical régulier
et lourd qui fait que je n'ai toujours
pas le temps de sortir ou d'honorer mes
invitations et socialement c'est très
perturbe au travail parfois les
interactions avec les collègues étaient
de plus en plus limité il ne comprenait
pas que je n'ai pas envie de parler
quand j'ai mes règles pendant que
j'avais très mal et que je gérais mon
souffle et réserve un peu d'énergie pour
tenir la journée et malgré tout ça il
m'arrive de trouver quelques instants de
rire et de joie même s'ils sont parfois
bref et écourtés à cause de mes douleurs
je les partage avec les personnes qui
acceptent l'endogirl que je suis
comprenne ce que je représente au
quotidien que nous traversions et qui
sont bienveillants aujourd'hui je parle
de mon endométriose avec un peu plus
d'assurance pourtant il n'a pas été
facile de l'annoncer autour de moi pour
surmonter à cela je me suis toujours
rappelée qu'il y a aucune honte à être
malade car le premier pas vers la
guérison et d'en parler quand on reçoit
un quelconque soutien cela aide beaucoup
que ce soit un soutien affectif matériel
ou même financier et le soutien
financier n'est pas du tout négligeable
car les soins d'une maladie chronique
tel que l'endométriose demande un
minimum de revenus et quand on est un
jeune étudiante comorienne s'embourse
comme moi à l'époque je peux vous
assurer que c'est très très compliqué
d'être malade dieu merci j'ai toujours
eu la chance et j'ai toujours cette
chance de compter sur ma famille surtout
mes sœurs elles n'ont jamais cessé de
m'appeler et de me soutenir dans tous
les sens du terme peu importe la
distance qui nous séparait elles ont
toujours été présentes et à
l'aboutissement du diagnostic et le sont
encore aujourd'hui dans mon suivi
médical dans ma quête de guérison j'ai
aussi trouvé d'autres formes
d'apaisement j'ai d'abord parlé
d'endométriose autour de moi comme avec
vous maintenant et j'ai découvert des
filles et des femmes dans ma situation
une nouvelle famille où il est simple de
se comprendre et de se soutenir j'ai
ensuite voulu en parler à plus de
personnes car plus on parle et plus j'en
le découvre aussi après avoir longuement
réfléchi j'ai décidé de lancer un
podcast sur les menstruations
le rapport avec la maternité les
douleurs le travail la vie sociale les
relations amoureuses la culture et bien
d'autres sujets qui gravitent autour je
les baptisé avec ou sans règles j'ai
trouvé que c'était le format idéal pour
partager mon vécu et ma vie avec les
règles et ce que d'autres femmes vivent
ou ont vécu avec leur règle j'espère
juste que certaines se retrouvent dans
mes récits ou dans mes échanges avec mes
invités et surtout que chacun de mes
épisodes leur sera bénéfique je crois
surtout que ce que je peux faire à mon
échelle c'est de contribuer et faire de
mon mieux à faire connaître cette
maladie aux filles et aux femmes
notamment celles qui souffrent de
douleurs menstruelles le rapport Témo
honnête et mes conseils que ce soit via
le podcast ou en étant leur écoute alors
je ne suis pas médecin mais je peux vous
dire que je suis une femme rodée par les
douleurs des règles et en échangeant
avec d'autres endogs j'en apprends
beaucoup sûrement aussi vu que je dois
composer avec cette maladie au quotidien
et que j'en apprends sur cette maladie
qui touche bientôt de fin de sur 10 si
on en parle pas et si les recherches
n'avancent pas la situation commence à
devenir vraiment inquiétante pour les
endogueurs il est donc très urgent d'en
parler mesdames ne doutez pas de vos
douleurs pendant les règles car personne
d'autre que vous ne vit dans votre corps
si vous supportez ces douleurs tant
mieux mais s'il y a un quelconque doute
il faut en parler et si ce n'est pas
l'endométriose c'est probablement autre
chose donc il faut toujours s'assurer
que tout va bien alors nous allons
continuer à en parler comme aujourd'hui
pour que les choses changent pour que
les prochaines générations puissent
mieux se faire soigner être mieux
accompagné et bénéficier d'une meilleure
prise en charge
le chemin est peut-être long mais c'est
le chemin qu'il faut prendre et pour me
motiver je me répète souvent cette
citation de l'écrivaine replicao je
saigne chaque mois pour permettre à
l'humanité d'exister personnellement
même si ce saignement est insupportable
j'apprends à vivre avec qui et avec tout
ce que cette maladie m'a fait traverser
j'ai trouvé un autre j'ai trouvé une
autre réponse à cette personne qui me
demandait quel était mon super pouvoir
je suis une battante courageuse
résiliente comorienne et en dehors et je
vous remercie pour votre attention